I think that this particular
problem with Brian Williams is part of a
larger phenomenon in television news.
It's become increasingly under siege
from so many alternatives,
first with Cable News,
alternatives,
and then with the Internet and mobile.
Uh,
and that's put enormous pressure on
these organizations.
Unfortunately in my view,
uh,
the organizations have responded by
taking their anchors and the reporters
and making them the story far too often.
Uh,
it's understandable.
It's a marketing decision.
It's a branding decision,
but it's not fundamentally what I
believe journalists should be doing.
Uh,
I spent years working with Peter
Jennings and Peter believed firmly and
we all embraced the notion that in the
end we're not the story.
We're reporting the story.
And as soon as the journalist becomes
the story,
you're in trouble.
You have pr staffs and marketing staffs
who are coaxing,
who are urging,
who are reinforcing any story that makes
their reporter or their anchor appear
larger than life.
I don't know.
When we decided that reporters have to
be war heroes,
reporters don't fight wars,
they report on worse.
And that,
as I say,
is not unique to Brian and that is not
unique to NBC News.
And therefore I am concerned about some
of the other news organizations who are
so quick to judge.
I can't predict what will happen to
Brian Williams.
In fact,
I don't think there's anyone who can
predict that right now because I'm not
sure anyone knows what all the facts
are.
The starting point is to find out what
the facts are.
Um,
what I do anticipate based on what I've
heard so far,
is that a NBC news will need to find a
way.
And I don't know what that way is.
I wouldn't dare try to tell them what
the way it is,
but I think they need to find a way to
send two messages.
And this is the hard part is you have to
send both messages provided Brian comes
through this.
And based on what I know right now,
I would expect him to.
You have to reinforce that you still
believe in him,
that you still value him,
that you value all of his years of
service,
and the wonderful journalism he's done
through the years,
number one,
and number two,
no one is above the truth.
This is the number one priority for any
news organization is to have their
credibility and their trustworthiness
and their relationship with the
audience,
and therefore they have to find some way
of planting a very big flag saying,
we believe in Brian,
but we really take this terribly
seriously.
This is more important than anything
else we do.